Have you ever trodden
on a Lego brick in your bare feet?
You’re tiptoeing through
your lounge late at night,
and suddenly that stabbing pain,
the expletives
and the inevitable question:
“Why do we have so much of this stuff
all over the place?”
Well, that’s really quite simple.
Your kids love playing with it,
so you buy more.
And a confession --
I love to watch my kids play with Lego.
Especially good is when
I see them inventing their own rules
and their own worlds.
So here are my daughters,
last Saturday,
making something out of different kits
and pieces of string
and pieces of wood and dolls
and other objects.
And I asked them, “What is it?”
And they said to me, “Dad, of course
it’s a princess flying on a dragon
to visit farm animals in New York.”
Of course, what else could it be?
Kids at play inspire me.
They’re not afraid to ask, “What if”
and “Why not?”
But what kids implicitly know
that adults tend to forget
is that play isn’t just about fun.
Now, as a biologist, I know that play
is spontaneous and pleasurable --
as you can see by the smiles
in this photograph --
but also, it accelerates
and derisks learning.
It helps kids to try out new behaviors,
to refine those behaviors
and to imagine what is not
but what could be or what will be.
As a business strategist
dealing with adults,
I still recommend play.
In fact, play in business
is not just possible,
I’d argue that it’s essential
and even urgent.
And here’s why.
Competitive advantage fades away
faster than any time in recent memory.
In the 1980s,
if you had a performance edge
over your competitors,
you could reasonably expect to continue
being a leader for around 10 years,
on average.
But now the half-life of that advantage
has shrunk to just one year.
That means that short-lived success
is actually still very common,
but sustained success  becomes very hard
and very rare.
That means that, actually, reimagination
is the new execution.
In order to stay on top,
or even just to tread water
and stay still,
you need to constantly
reimagine your business.
But that’s not so simple
if you already have
a highly successful business model.
We become prisoners of the mental models
that underpin our past success.
In fact, I found
in dealing with businesses
that you can’t really
stretch your strategy
unless you stretch your mind.
Now play is of course a great way
of stretching your mind.
Now --
I mean, there’d be no mistake,
I’m not suggesting literally
that executives huddle around
a conference table
with a big pile of Lego bricks --
although I’ve done that,
and that works too.
But instead, I’ve created a series
of imagination games
to help executives
to stretch their thinking.
Would you like to play with me?
(Audience nods)
Good, I'm glad you said that.
OK, so let’s supposing
that you’re stuck in the rut
of seeing the world through the lens
of your past and current success.
I would recommend the “Anti-Company Game,”
and here’s how it works.
You get a piece of paper,
you create a list of everything
which is essential to your strategy --
everything which underpinned
your past success,
everything which is core and sacred --
and then you flip it.
You create the exact
mirror-image list of assumptions,
and then you make the best
business case for this antiself.
You’ll be surprised
at the ideas that it triggers.
Supposing, for example,
that you’re the CEO of a hotel chain
and playing the game
and flipping the assumptions.
Let’s assume that, inconveniently,
you don’t actually own any hotels
or any rooms
or even operate any hotels
or any rooms anywhere.
Ridiculous --
quite possibly --
but actually, how would you know
the difference between ridiculous
and the merely unfamiliar,
untried and uncomfortable?
And who’s to say
that something that seems impractical
can’t actually become and evolve
into a more powerful idea?
Actually, had the executives of hotels
played the “Anti-Company Game”
before 2007,
they might have been able to foresee
the appearance of Airbnb,
the hotel-less hospitality company,
and they might have been able
to stave off disruption
by preemptively disrupting themselves.
Let’s play another game:
“The Maverick Game.”
On the edge of your industries --
on the edge of every industry --
are a population of maverick companies
that are taking a bet against
the incumbents’ business model
and their view of the future.
Actually, they have no choice
because to be a miniature version
of the incumbent would not be viable.
Now, it’s easy not to notice them --
many of them are small companies.
It's easy to deliberately overlook
them with some justification.
Many startups disappear fairly quickly
after being founded.
And it’s very, very tempting,
given all of your experience
in the business,
to judge them.
Do they know what they’re doing?
Does their business model make sense?
Will they ever make any money?
But instead of judging them
from the comfort
and the confidence of your position,
try assuming that it’s they that have
the right bet on the future.
Think about the consequences
of that for your business model.
Try making the best case for their idea.
Supposing, for example,
that you are the CEO of a company
that makes equipment
that makes semiconductors.
Naturally, you’d probably spend
most of your time and attention
on your main customer industry,
the electronics industry.
And if it so happened,
that a couple of maverick
bioscience companies
were tinkering with your patents
and your technologies,
you might overlook that
as a distraction,
an irrelevance.
But actually, Brooks Automation,
a leader in the field,
decided to take a close-up look
at such a group of mavericks
to see whether it could learn anything.
And what it realized
by looking at the world
through the eyes of these mavericks
was that, actually, the same techniques
and technologies which can be used
to handle delicate semiconductors
can also be applied to other fragile
and easily contaminated materials,
like biological samples.
And puzzling on the significance of this,
they reimagined how to handle
and store and transport
and label and identify biological samples.
In fact, they became a successful pioneer
in the new industry
of automated biobanking.
So successful, in fact,
that just a couple of days ago,
they announced that this was now
their core business moving forwards.
It’s only by focusing
on these anomalous mavericks
that they could see their own path
to renewed success and growth.
Now, not everything in business
goes according to plan.
In fact, sometimes the plans
go horribly awry.
But you know what?
That can be a source of inspiration, too.
To find out how,
let’s play the “Pre-Mortem Game.”
So your role in this game is to write ...
the obituary for your company,
which is going to fail
with 100 percent certainty
in five years’ time.
What is the cause of death?
What will have been the point of failure?
Why will it have failed?
How will it have failed?
The challenge here is that it’s easy
to be seduced into the baseline fallacy.
The baseline fallacy is the idea
that it’s the current business model
which is the low-risk bet.
And of course that tends to be true
until it isn’t true,
at which point it’s probably too late
to do anything about it.
Now, your employees
are an early-warning indicator.
They will have intuitions
if the model begins to slip,
but it’s very hard for them to speak up.
And it’s even taboo for them to speak up
when the business model is under pressure.
But when executives create playgrounds --
spaces for the safe exploration
of alternatives
and alternative scenarios --
then you get to tap into your employees’
considerable experience
about the vulnerabilities
and the weak spots
and the blind spots of your company.
Does anyone remember visiting recently
one of these gorgeous marble palaces?
No?
It’s probably been a while since
we visited the local banking branch.
Had bricks-and-mortar banks
played the “Pre-Mortem Game,”
perhaps they would have heard
their employees expressing some concerns
about the gradually dwindling
flow of customers to local branches.
And perhaps they would have been
slightly less taken by surprise
when companies like NewBank,
a digital native,
seized, very rapidly indeed,
on that opportunity
to convince, to date,
more than 40 million Latin Americans
that in-person transactions
in real buildings
were a quaint but obsolete
relic of the past.
It’s only when you bring
your vulnerabilities into full view
in this way
that you may be motivated
to reimagine your business
and to do so in a robust manner.
It’s why the Roman Catholic Church
invented the role,
the position of the Devil’s advocate
in the 16th century
to test the future consequences
of its decisions to appoint new saints.
They did that by imagining
what would Satan say
or propose
or counterpropose,
in addition to the normal procedure
of thinking about the big man upstairs.
Now, any human being,
any employee, any team
and therefore any company
can harness human imagination.
It’s a defining trait of our species.
Failures to imagine in business
are really failures of leadership.
Business is a serious matter,
but it should not exclude play.
When leaders embrace play
and imagination games,
they can unlock the imagination
of their employees,
uncover disruptive new strategies
and renew their lease on the future.
Thank you.
(Applause)